I always thought you know a snow shoe
would really make a great cello a wooden
chair back makes a cool guitar body but
turns out that one of my most playable
instruments is is a golf club I'm seeing
that transformative quality in my head
all the time
what can I say out I'm attracted to
trash there's no way check out the Jimi
Hendrix of shovel is a guitar made up of
lots of will jump he even plays his
zipper from Brooklyn New York welcome
ken vampire my name is Ken Butler I'm an
artist and musician and known for
building my own experimental instruments
since 1978 I think I've made around 400
instruments this whole thing started for
me when I was in my basement in Portland
Oregon and I saw a rusty old beat-up
hatchet put two strings and two tuning
pegs on it plugged it into my guitar amp
and was quite stunned that it actually
sounded like a horrible violin the ax
violin was the first time that somebody
said that's a cool idea
[Music]
if I go walking around the neighborhood
everywhere you look you see such amazing
conglomerations of potential sculpture
there's crutches tennis rackets parts of
furniture boom
I'm right there with that you know what
I build stringed instruments really just
need three things the head the neck and
the body a spoon has that parameter a
key looks like a guitar as you know and
then it's little body this is from a
very inexpensive mandolin of course some
of the things become crazy Baroque
assemblages of multiple multiple necks
it's ridiculous but that's how it works
my shovel guitar I guess it's a small
snow shovel it's just a four key object
and it sounds unbelievably beautiful the
qualities and characters at the golf
club has is amazing
this one is made from a beach paddle
that has a of the ukelele neck and a
team
sometimes people think my intention is
humour it's not
I think it's surprising to people when I
can generate genuine emotion and meaning
and real music on something as
ridiculous as a hockey stick or tennis
racket or a broom or a shovel or a golf
club at the real core of what I'm doing
is to communicate to other people that
the things right around them can be
magical and transformative and even
spiritual hill knows if if I hadn't
found that axe what would have happened
I want to give it to scrap life again
bringing a new purpose my eyes mix of
fantasy common sense
my name is kaya koogler and I'm an
artist and I'm most known for making
moving robots cultures they stumbled
into making robots I was making
sculptures out of scrap metal I found
and then I started to move those moving
parts with air pressure Pistons that
started with a head moving the jaw and
before I knew it I had a robot
I found myself pretty much everywhere
I've got my eyes open all the time
potentially fantastic I there's every
kind of shape you can imagine
[Applause]
[Music]
when I've built I remember I start
obviously with of music making parts of
fingers plugging appliance and then I
built the carrot from behind it
the special thing about my robot is to
actually do play the music themselves my
robot plays the bass guitar to drumkit
and they play the flute they're gonna
finish for punk rock the whole band is
called to unlock the sheet back
my robot perform all around the world
tech events festivals university
lectures or TED Talks when people see
the robot it slightly fries for a while
there's this moment of hope what's going
on here and then it's very easily that
it's a childish gleamin and joy I'd like
to use scrap marker because there's so
much where to the world trying to so you
can only make it better
my work is a constant game of chance and
that's what I really love about it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a nice instrument has the purity and the
clarity of the heavenly realm it's not
of the earth in the way that a wooden
instrument would be there's so much
potential in ice as an acoustic material
[Music]
my name is Tim Lynn Hart and I am the
founder of ice music ice music is the
music that we make on this Orchestra of
ice instruments the idea first came to
me about 21 years ago I was an ice
sculptor for many years he decided one
of my sculptures I'd like to build a
giant violin and I had a friend who was
building guitars and he just asked the
question gee I wonder how that one's
going to sound and that question has
swallowed much of the rest of my life
[Music]
the instruments are made of white ice
which is a mixture of snow and water
it's filled with as snowflakes and air
bubbles and they're all kind of
different things going on to make a
single instrument of violin or viola
here the ice part takes about five or
six days I can probably build the whole
Orchestra here in about seven or eight
weeks we have violins violas cellos bass
guitars mandolins
banjos drums and xylophone
[Music]
ice music is not just classical music or
experimental music it's a wide variety
of different things
this winter we'll put on about 45
concerts the concert hall has a specific
design it's one giant ice cave the igloo
right now is ten degrees Fahrenheit it's
definitely an issue in ice music that
people's fingers get cold people play
with a variety of different kinds of
gloves
some people play barehanded but for me
the temperature is you know the thing
that I really need to make ice music
work so many people just cannot wrap
their brain around a piece of ice making
a sound or a beautiful sound when they
come into the ice concert hall and
they're just very very pleasantly
surprised and that releases a real kind
of a high for people and then wow it's
it's amazing
[Music]
[Music]
very often people think it's gonna be
funny and then they realize it's not
really
we really do music it's not impossible
to make music with vegetables my name is
Susanna Katya and then I'm a member of
the vegetable orchestra the orchestra
exists since 18 years now if there's
instrument was the tomato because you
can do sound with tomatoes but it will
be messy for sure we go shopping on the
market first we choose all the
vegetables there we have three kinds of
instruments one is the ready mate you
can just buy it at the market and play
it it's like the pepper it's cold no
it's ready already and then there are
the simple instruments like with one cut
or some cuts to get it like that then
with the more complex instruments we
have some that work like normal
instruments you know the pumpkin is the
bass drum and the sound of the pumpkin
is really important after shopping we go
to the venue and start to build
instruments all in all it takes two to
three hours to paint all the instruments
for everybody and then we start with the
soundcheck and since we have new
instruments each time we have to have a
very long story
[Music]
[Applause]
we have a lot of different musical
influences in the orchestra since we're
really many people everybody's
interested in different things we make a
soup during the building process of the
vegetable instruments with the remaining
vegetables when we serve it to the
audience after the concert and it's also
after hearing and seeing us and smelling
the vegetables which will be intense in
there because it's so small this theater
and then you can also eat it you never
get it out of your head anymore if
you're in the orchestra to look
vegetables in another way
[Applause]